bed van Shack wanted to meet firsthand
with rohingya victims government
officials and Aid agency workers during
her visit to the camp the Ambassador for
Global criminal justice said the U.S
government has determined that crimes
against humanity as well as genocide
have been committed against the rohingya
people my trip was incredibly inspiring
it was really fascinating to hear from
the individuals there what they are
doing to advance Justice
in their own communities so I spoke with
documentors who are working out in the
camps taking testimony from survivors
the refugees Camp leader shamsal Alam
said he was disappointed that there has
been no progress holding those
responsible for atrocities accountable
we're happy the diplomats from America
and other countries are now visiting the
camp it's almost six years since we've
been living here there's not much
progress I hope that justice will
prevail
for the refugees life here is
challenging the camp is overcrowded and
overflowing there are flimsy shelters
and the refugees are hammed in by
Barbara fencing here there are no formal
education for children available no
possibility of work and no travel
allowed
the most serious problem that we are
facing is that we are not able to
educate our children nor do we have any
means of earning here making it hard to
make ends meet
Ambassador Sheikh says that the
international code of justice and the
international criminal code play the
lead role in bringing Justice for the
rohingya my office in the state
department is ultimately a foreign
policy diplomatic office and our goal is
to provide assistance wherever we can
information sharing diplomatic support
working with survivors to enable them to
travel to get the kind of papers they'll
need to travel to the various
jurisdictions whatever we can to help
move these processes forward
most refugees don't feel it's safe for
them to return home
I'm still
not brought to justice for what happened
to the rohingyas and there's no sign of
repatriation most of those who sought
refugees here are getting increasingly
frustrated losing hope of ever returning
home
Bangladesh is a willing and generous
host to the rohingya but after six years
it wants the International Community to
do more to resolve the crisis that shows
no sign of ending tanvi Chaudhary Al
Jazeera Dhaka